hi I'm Fred Shapiro I'm the associate
director of the law library here at Yale
I'm also the editor of the new Yale book
of quotations and I'm here to talk about
that book and talk about a few of the
quotations that I particularly like or
that are particularly meaningful and and
why I selected them
[Music]
black lives matter obviously is a very
big quote in our political and social
life and it was first coined by a a
writer an activist named Alicia Garza
we're living in a very turbulent crazy
time which has generated many remarkable
quotes and black lives matter it's a
very short quote it's really a slogan
but it's has had such a tremendous
influence on our culture and our
politics in recent years that I think
it's merits speak for themselves believe
those who are seeking the truth doubt
those who find it by the French writer
andrejid this encapsulates the one of
the big issues of our time which is
truth and
accuracy versus Fabrications IT
addresses the phenomenon which is so
prevalent now of people that are
Fanatics or narrowly focused on a
particular agenda
nobody loves me but my mother and she
could be jiving too by the musician BB
King there is a lot of humor in the book
a lot of wit and humor and I
particularly like this quote I'd like to
include quotes from the Arts from the
music world and this one I just thought
was a particularly funny one
I am not smart but genius and a very
stable genius at that Donald J Trump
this quote is amazing on many levels
this is someone who many people feel is
not smart and not a genius and not
stable uh but yet he he Prides himself
on those those very attributes this is
not a book that only has admirable
eloquent quotations it has quotations
that are famous that's one of the big
criteria for inclusion quotations that
are historically important and uh Mr
Trump has many of those
there's nothing to be learned from
history anymore we're in science fiction
Now by Alan Ginsberg I know I personally
have the sense but maybe many others
have the sense that what we're not we're
we've crossed some kind of divide that
instead of watching post-apocalyptic
movies maybe we're living in a
post-apocalyptic movie and that's uh
what Ginsburg was meaning to convey even
a few decades ago when he said that
quote
I don't want to belong to any club that
would accept me as one of its members by
Groucho Marx and this is a quote that
has a lot of
psychological uh
validity that many people feel
God grant me the serenity to accept the
things I cannot change courage to change
the things I can and wisdom to know the
difference this is the the famous
serenity prayer and it has a very
complex and Rich origin story it's
usually attributed to Reinhold niebuhr
who is a great Theologian and a great
political philosopher I've done a lot of
research on this prayer almost 20 years
have been studying this neighbor's
daughter says that in 1943 was when her
father sat down and wrote it but if you
search newspaper indexes newspaper
databases you'll find that it was used
as far back as 1933 the earliest record
we have of someone using it was a woman
named Winifred Weigel an official of the
YWCA
wrote The Serenity Prayer we believe and
she's the earliest known user of it and
she is a completely obscure woman
Reinhold neighbor is a very very famous
man and this is actually a pattern that
I found in preparing my book that there
are many famous quotes by obscure women
that are attributed to famous men
prominent men and this I think is the
most interesting example of that and in
my book I go into some detail and
explaining the story the true story of
the serenity prayer and its Origins
[Music]